foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
tonight on Facebook and uncensored a
jaw-dropping world exclusive is one of
the defining musicians of his generation
and one of the most controversial people
alive tonight I'll go head to head with
the artists formerly known as Kanye West
[Music]
from New York this is Piers Morgan
uncensored
well good evening welcome to a special
edition of Piers Morgan on census from
New York Kanye West now known as simply
as yay one-on-one
[Music]
he's one of the defining artists of this
generation with 24 Grammys and more than
160 million records sold producer
fashion designer billionaire
the artist formerly known as Kanye West
is quite simply a mega star yeah he's
six year marriage to Kim Kardashian made
them both Titans of the tabloids I had
to go to La and come back so I just
traveled to get something for Kev
thank you for Kanye and for his
unbelievable way he does things and the
ability to get something done but lately
it's his opinions that are stolen the
headlines first he wore White lives
matter t-shirt at a Paris fashion show
next he shot the world with a series of
anti-Semitic terrains including a tweet
threatening Defcon 3 on Jewish people
now suspended from social media and with
his Adidas deal in Jeopardy yeah has
doubled down
spreading unfounded conspiracy theories
about George Floyd which is now being
sued by the family if you look the guy's
knee wasn't even on his neck like that
is he malicious is he misunderstood is
he just a racist was he mentally unwell
tonight yeah he gets the chance to set
the record straight yay is one of the
most influential people on the planet of
that there's no doubt he's just
announced that he's buying the social
media platform parlor he has physical
Ambitions too and because of his profile
his recent offensive comments have
called Global outrage as well as ongoing
speculation about his health well
tonight I give yay the opportunity to
explain and perhaps reconsider or maybe
even apologize for some of those
comments some of the things he says in
this interview are in my opinion
anti-semitic and defensive we're airing
them in the context of an interview in
which I try to understand why he made
his comments what he really meant by
them and whether he understands the
anger that his words have caused what
follows is a gripping fiery shocking
sometimes funny sometimes Bonkers
interview and at the end of it you can
make your own mind up about yay yay
thank you very much indeed for joining
Piers Morgan uncensored my first
question for you I guess is an obvious
one what do you hope to achieve from our
conversation
uh that right there being uncensored
in American Media it's very censored
it's it feels like an episode of Black
Mirror a lot of times there's so many
people everywhere I know everyone can
relate to being afraid to say what
you're going to feel because you feel
like you're gonna
you know you're going to lose something
so whether you agree with me or not
I believe people are going to feel the
fact that someone is brave enough to say
something because when you take people
like Elon Musk and Bernard are no and uh
Trump or uh Jack ma uh Putin you take
these people in their own space in their
own environments you know we can start
to feel like God's on Earth but we are
nothing in comparison to God and we are
here actually to love one another and to
collaborate and to make the world a
better place there's you know one
percent of the world are placed in power
and 99 of the world are the audience so
that one percent of the world this idea
of the United Nations this is the world
that needs to come together this is the
world that I mean here's the obvious
go-to Biden doesn't listen to Elon Musk
the president of the United States does
not have meetings with Elon Musk that is
hey here come come come get me that's
[ __ ]
I know I'm not supposed to say that
Biden but that's [ __ ]
Biden and obviously because I've been
deemed with mental health all this I
have the right to use whatever words
that I like to use well that's
interesting so somebody ask another
question oh yeah let me ask you on that
so you just you just said something very
inflammatory about President Biden it
will as you know offend a lot of people
and it will particularly offend people
who work in mental health you say you
should not use a word like [ __ ] but
you say that because you yourself have
had mental health issues that entitles
you to use that kind of word as an
insult now I would say that's an
arguable Point I've had my issue my
issue is I've had mental health
allegations let me ask you yeah if I can
about the allegations that you have made
anti-semitic comments and in particular
when you said on Instagram I'm a bit
sleepy tonight but when I wake up I'm
going Defcon 3 on Jewish people now many
people who are Jewish found that deeply
offensive they wanted to know what did
you mean by going Defcon 3 on Jewish
people because deathcon 3 as you know is
a heightened state of awareness for
military action so what did you mean by
that what was here's your chance to
clarify what you meant by Defcon 3 on
Jewish people well thank you for
allowing me to say what I meant due to
the fact that I was blocked by Jewish
people after I said that so it wasn't
actually allowed to say what I was about
to say being that I'm an Entertainer
I've been wronged so many times by
Jewish businessmen and the reason why I
say people if a black man is caught in
the car with drugs or a gun and there's
three other black guys in the car with
them guess what they're all going to
jail so the reason why I say people is I
want those businessmen's wives and
fathers mothers grandmothers and kids to
ask them why is yay so mad
at us because they're taking money out
of my children's mouths so I'm in a
point where I'm frustrated I have the
right to my anger and I'm saying that
people need to fix it I'm not going to
fix what I feel until what I'm feeling
is fixed okay can I respond that's just
gonna shut me up and say no I'm not
going to shut you up can I respond to
what you just said
my problem with what you've said I'll be
straight with you is if I as a white man
posted tomorrow on my Instagram I'm a
bit sleepy tonight but when I wake up
I'm going Defcon 3 on black people
what would you think did you no no if I
said black people what would you think
if that was what I posted what did you
accept that black people you accepted
that black people are Jew or no but no
no no I'll come to that in a moment on
the specific note if I simply said in
other words all black people was the
implication of what I said I would get
rightly canceled I would get rightly
vilified and abused you I suspect would
be outraged by a white person saying
such a thing because you wouldn't make
any distinction about whether I was
talking about certain black business
people I'd fallen out with or whatever
you would think I was judging an entire
populace by the color of their skin You
Are by saying Jewish people on Jewish
people you're not saying Jewish
businessmen accountants whatever that
you've had a problem with you're
basically saying in that statement all
Jewish people which is why it caused
such offense and I'm curious whether you
even as you wrote those words understood
what Jewish people actually would feel
when you said that and didn't make any
uh specific references to any
individuals
maybe they would feel how all my people
have felt maybe they would feel the pain
of when a black artist looks up and
they've been completely they've
completely been raped by five Jewish
businessmen and there's multiple
accounts why does the fact that they're
Jewish have anything to do with it feel
like that but why why would you say it
just so happens they are well okay but I
wouldn't why categorize them according
to their religious Faith their ethnicity
why would do that why can't you just
describe them as business people that
you've dealt with
that's fine but what you're doing by
saying Jewish people these constant
tiradesier against Jewish people
that sounds like you have it I think
it's a time what is the tirade that was
just that was a tweet it was a tweet
you asked me to explain it and that have
you felt my pain yet you haven't felt my
pain I've you know I know you don't hold
a counter la la la la la la la you don't
hold accountability to my pain you're
being a Karen I'm talking about I'm
talking about pain I'm not a Karen I'm
not going to cancel you and I'm not
going to uncens you I'm simply going to
challenge you on what you're saying I
think you don't understand the pain that
you've been causing with some of these
comments and I think that one in
particular I can understand God God
forbid God forbid one comment could
cause people to feel any of the pain
that my people have went through for
years even like the blacks being ushered
to the left during the Civil Rights
Movement no one is cared okay
I don't know all right no one is can I
let me say I agree that the racism
against black people has been utterly
deplorable shameful unacceptable and
thank God the world is beginning to move
to a better place
however however one form of racism is in
a better place
I'm not cutting you off I'm finishing my
sentences you can respond once more
racism
racism it is racism when you say I'm
going down
that's racism no it's not I thought I
thought I thought you I thought you had
I thought you had a a platform where I
could explain how I felt you don't care
about how I feel you just want to shut
me up you don't want me to say out loud
what my people have been going through I
do
or do I do I'm very happy so what if my
people have been going through what what
led me to that point
my point is me a person a successful a
successful influential extremely
extremely extremely attractive person to
get to that point
I am not doubting for a moment that you
will feel genuine pain about the racism
against you and other black people in
America not for one second
would I deny that racism by who by
anybody I think anything of racism is
wrong any form of racism is wrong I
don't I I didn't say I didn't say Defcon
or anybody though you said Defcon 3 on
Jewish people specifically Jewish people
you didn't say any particular Jewish
person you said basically all of them
that is racism yay and I think if you
were honest with yourself give them the
Fallout from this you would think again
about how you phrase that sentence
because actually you didn't mean all
Jewish people give you a Fallout
given the Fallout within the Fallout do
you care about the hurt because Jewish
people fall out well you were removed
from where is that you were removed from
social media but I feel the anti-semite
has been a wall a cloak that allows
Jewish businessmen boom I'll only be the
police officer that says hey this guy
with the gun is the only person going to
jail I'll be the first person that does
that in history right no one else in
this car riding with the guy with the
gun and the drugs is going to jail are
you happy I play by rules that are not
played by for my people just for the
sake of this I don't want you playing by
anything that makes you happy right I
don't want I don't want you to say
anything that's what colonizers do is
give us rules what you've just said is
not what you said on your Instagram post
and you know it right if you have a
problem with particular businessmen
that is a concern for you and you know
it so you talk about it all Jewish
brother can we brother do you what is
the point brother do you want me to grow
from the statement I just told you okay
I was in a position where I've been hurt
and this is the way I had the right to
express myself the point of this
interview is for you to question me and
then for me to answer and say okay even
though the same rules are not applied to
my people if a person with a gun or
drugs is pulled over and has four three
other people in the car they're all
going to jail I'm not going to apply
that to Jewish people for the sake of
this conversation isn't that what you
wanted but you know what you did you
tried the Civil Rights me you tried to
pull me back to a week ago but we're
here today there's been plenty of
Commerce conversations of commentary
since that but you want me to go back to
1960s
all right let me jump in here's what I
want you to do I want you to do okay so
have we grown
yes here's how we grow I want
I'm about to suggest to you how you may
grow if you choose to grow this way and
you can you can ignore me you can ignore
me Pierce Pierce how much money are you
worth not as much as you sadly
exactly so take my advice maybe you'll
get richer I would love to take your
businesses why would I listen to you why
do you why do you hear what my advice is
and then work out if I'm wrong can we do
that deal
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
my question for you is do you now regret
saying
on Jewish people are you sorry you said
that
nothing it matters you should be
absolutely not you should be absolutely
not yeah but yeah you should be
absolutely not are are the are the
people the Jewish businessmen that led
me to that place are they sorry for the
way they've raped I don't know who
you're talking about in particular but I
don't know why you keep having to say
what is the fact that Jewish got to do
with anything why do you keep what do
you mean they're the Jewish businessmen
that did that because they're business
people that's what they do why do you
keep saying Jewish business people why
do you keep using their religion I mean
their ethnicity why they keep doing that
let me update it then okay okay so I'll
say this
would it be would would I have grown
into the box you want me to go on if I
say to specify the business people that
have raped my people that just so
happened to be Jewish
I think what by doing what you've just
done I find that I'm not even Jewish and
I find that offensive why do you keep
having to do that I don't think you get
it at all I know you understand the
offense you're causing when you keep
using their religious background their
ethnicity so what does a stick to beat
them with why would you do that
so what are you more concerned about
getting the richest black man of all
time the cow tell because it's not going
to happen I don't want you to count so
you can do what the hell you like you're
you're gay you're you know billionaire
you can do whatever the hell you want
I'm just I'm just saying to you that I
don't think you quite understand when
you talk about uh okay can I finish it's
not uh multi multi you're a
multi-billionaire okay well
congratulations but that doesn't change
the fact that when you insult the Jewish
people and say you're going Defcon 3 on
the Jewish people that is as racist as
anything you say you've been through and
any pain that you've experienced it's
the same thing racism is racism
and you know that I think don't you
yeah obviously that's why I said it
so you said it knowing it's racist
yes I fought fire with fire okay I'm not
here to get hoes down at least that's a
different type of freedom fighter that's
honest all right you were racist because
you knew it was racist but you decided
to do that because people have been
racist to you I can't be anti-semite I
love Jewish people I work with Jewish
people yo watch this watch this some of
my best friends are Jewish right so you
know how that's how many times have you
heard that statement of course but the
funny thing is they are I work with Dove
Charney that got kicked out of his
company out of American Apparel I work
with this guy every day he's like my
twin he's one of my favorite people in
the planet and we work through that we
talked through and he says yay why are
you so mad and I'm like this is why I'm
mad this contract right here what's
gonna happen before I'm done we're gonna
open up all of the music industry
contracts all of the publishing deals
all of the athlete deals all of the
acting deals all of the mortgages that's
all fine you can do it but it has to
start somewhere of course you can do all
that and when you do that somewhere I
hope you won't be judged as a black
business this person doing it all the
time that people don't phrase it all the
time by the color of your skin but by
your business Acumen isn't that what you
would like isn't that what equality
actually means and of course I'll be
judged by that because when people come
into power
people get judged yeah I'm saying like
there's nobody that gets judged more
than a straight white male and so I
empathize with the position
of the straight white male and part of
the reason why I empathize with that
position is because I know that I'm
headed to that position and what
position that is that is top power
position okay that's the top power
position where you get all the Rocks
thrown and that's that's the thing I
have friends right that will like
you know actually that's the reason why
I'm gonna be a good leader someday
because I'm really empathetic but I call
black people out on their stuff I call
white people out on their stuff because
we're all people we're actually only one
species and in order to whether it's my
friends texting me like bro you got to
get in the gym you're looking chubby in
the photo you know it's like we have to
hold
each other accountable to what's
actually happening and it's so much is
based on you did that tweet wrong so
what I will say is I feel that my words
demand more sensitivity for the
frequency that I'm operating at and that
and the amount of people that I'm
communicating to and I take that
responsibility right now but I will also
say everything happens for a reason
because if it had been perfectly worded
in English
and because there's nothing wider than
English itself right I'm already not
speaking in my mother tongue right so uh
if I had perfectly worded it and the
most sensitive way then we wouldn't be
here right now now we're opening up the
conversation like there I'm not allowed
to say whether or not I'm running for
office in 2024 but I'll tell you what if
the left let's say the left
the left would have never supported me
anyway
and now I've got to call to attention I
am who you should support the left did
not allow Trump to be president they
treated him like he wasn't even the
president so even then he won he was
losing half of the American people every
day and it divided the country what I'm
saying whoever goes into office for uh
British media for American Media we must
support our leaders and not just run
this hyper negative you know what I will
uh and black people hate when I
apologize for this when I see people
like John Legend and Chrissy Teigen talk
down on the president I'm like wow that
kind of sounds like me that kind of
sounds like the Telethon I opened up
this level of disrespect towards our
leaders and people are happy ah and the
left saw that and say well let's just
have every celebrity do what yay did at
the Telethon so I take responsibility
for that moment and you know what I just
want to give every Jewish person a big
hug also I'm envious of the Jewish
people I'm envious of how they don't
abort their children I'm envious of how
they don't shoot each other in the
streets and then rap about it I'm
envious of how their their families stay
together I'm envious that they turn
their phones off on Friday night and the
family comes together I'm envious of how
they do the business together and I want
that for the darker Jews I want that for
the black people I want that we need
that God said we should remove the word
want right we're going to have that and
this is the beginning of it but it seems
to me and correct me if I'm wrong but it
seems to me that you are acknowledging
as you've just acknowledged that it was
wrong to say what you said about
President Bush when he doesn't care
about black people that may have
encouraged all this disrespect towards
Presidents since I think it's an
interesting point you made it does seem
to me yay talking to you that even if
it's hard for you to admit this that you
do regret the wording of that tweet
which caused all the problems and you
wouldn't phrase it that way again am I
right
I would tell I would tell my dad that my
dad loved the White lives matter t-shirt
because what audacity does a black man
have to wear the exact same t-shirt that
a white man could wear
you know and my dad was a black panther
I mean we have a water purification
Center you know he's like the original
Steve Jobs he's the educated version of
me right and he and he liked
both of those things but he said you
know yeah he even calls me yay now he's
like Yay if you you've got to be more
sophisticated with your wording and that
wording like I said I'm a bit sleepy and
it lacked the sophistication needed to
be the true conductor that I am because
it's the conductor's job to bring people
together and that was divisive which is
not who I want to be right so no so I'll
tell you that I'm not looking and also
let me let me besides sometimes
I want to I want to talk okay let me let
me say that I'm just thinking right now
so my heart is the idea for people who
do actually have severe mental health
issues you know the word [ __ ] for
you know there's parents that have
children who actually are mentally ill
and that word
is really offensive right to those
people so why use it and and just
because yeah just because I was I was
feeling
um
uh
uh what's a couple reasons because
people call me [ __ ] they treat me
like I'm [ __ ] uh and so I embrace it
it's like you call somebody so much they
say I'm
you call somebody a [ __ ] so much they
say I'm a [ __ ] you call somebody a
[ __ ] somebody she say I'm [ __ ]
like I was exhausted and I embraced the
idea
of having a serious mental health uh
issue but Noah I mean not Noah Noah also
but Moses was basically on speed when he
was doing what he did
out of Interest yeah how much sleep do
you get a night
I don't I I'm not here to talk about how
much sleep I get I don't literally just
been talking about how much sleep do how
much sleep do you get in there I had
about five and a half hours last night
actually not very much
um but but you're the one that's raised
this issue and I probably had the same
right my questions everybody had the
same but it's only because you've been
talking about you don't believe you have
a mental illness you think it's lack of
sleep so I think it's an obvious
question to ask well how much sleep do
you get do you are you constantly sleep
deprived is that is that one of the
reasons perhaps sometimes as you say you
feel sleepy and you shoot from the hip
verbally and you say stuff that maybe
when you're rested you wouldn't say it
the same way would that be fair tell me
what's
okay no it's not fair because what's
more important
the pain and the truth of what I'm
talking about and what led me to that
tweet or the Tweet itself
I think both can be true because the
problem you have is I think you've
acknowledge I think you've acknowledged
that the word
yes I understand but you know the damage
it caused and I think I understand that
that was offensive and I think that you
have accepted
no near no no you as a white person are
so stuck on the idea that what I said
was offensive which is a very caring
approach you're not sticking on the fact
you have not unpacked what happened with
those contracts I've said that but you
didn't ask me another question about it
that means there's an agenda absolutely
I have repeatedly said to you that I'm
sure I I do not disbelieve that you've
had contract business issues with
various managers accountants and so on
my argument is that when you do this or
other means I'm sure mainly I'm sure
many other artists in the music business
yeah of course you know why you're sure
or because because you don't care to do
the research because it doesn't affect
you no it's because you said you've done
any research no yay let me explain to
you I'm not doubting what you don't care
I do care you don't care about me you
don't care about my people I care about
me I care about my people so as for me
to stand up and God forbid I step on
someone's toes while I'm at it it's not
some monsters you stepped on the entire
Jewish people's toes with a very deeply
inflammatory tweet which I think you've
now accepted you shouldn't have phrase
that way it's taken a bit of time to get
there but I think you have accepted that
right
have you accepted that you've put no
effort into understanding how I got
there
I don't think I don't think honestly 10
years from now honestly I don't think
there is apologize to me about this
interview I'm not you're gonna apologize
to me about this interview within the
next 10 years no I'm not because here's
the thing my words I don't doubt you've
had it's very one-sided notice it's very
it's very white-sided
it's very like it's not white-sided I'm
not doubting you've had business issues
I'm saying the way to respond to that is
Jewish people millions of people
millions of people have had Defcon 3 on
their contracts right you didn't you
didn't say anything you didn't say that
said millions of people well I open it
up not I didn't but now I'm saying it
now okay so now what I said you should
say I think you should say to the Jewish
people I'm sorry for the offensive
language I used in that tweet I wouldn't
do that again this is what I really
meant I think people would respect you
if you said that I don't know why you
can't just say that house let me you
know you know you know when I'll say it
when I sit down with the people who
write out the contracts for the MBA and
for the NFL and for professional music
and for uh acting contracts we need to
go to the top lawyers the top execs the
owners of the stadiums the owners of the
football teams and the owners of the
record labels and we're going to put
them all in one room and we're going to
read every dot let's go top 10 in each
one of these categories right let's read
Michael B Jordan why would any of us
hey bro hey hey bro I ain't finished I
ain't finished my sentence
hey boy don't finish I told you
oh don't treat me like a boy then I'm
gonna finish my sentence or my idea
nothing you're saying has got anything
to do with the Tweet cool
so I was in the middle of a sentence boy
okay so are you going to allow me to
finish my sentence yes
if you then answer my question Okay so
okay so I'm gonna tell people when I
would apologize for the tweet this is
what has to happen first
I need all of the top Executives in
Hollywood I need the top Executives at
the MBA and at the NFL we'll do those
two sports specifically and I want the
top Executives in music dealing with
publishing dealing with uh like Spotify
and apple music and uh Universal Music
and all the topics that uh let's do like
five topics X there and I want to look
at the top 10 earners and each one of
those fields contracts openly we want to
compare and contrast the contracts and
then once we open that conversation and
we need to do it on a platform live with
lawyers asking questions and we'll and
we'll have the top lawyers like a Johnny
Cochran Robert Kardashian level legal
team you know looking at all of these
contracts together after that moment
happens then I will say I'm sorry
okay if that's your position point of
view interview adjourned love you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
this is talk TV
[Music]
welcome back to the special edition of
Piers Morgan on census from New York
Kanye West known as simply as yay 101
yay thanks for sitting back down I'll
change the subject now a lot of stuff
has been written about you and your
family uh a lot of it fueled by you by
Kim by others where are things now with
your family what is what is your
relationship like with Kim with your
kids
Kim has
zionists media handlers
surrounding her all in and out her Hulu
TV show all in and out her her family
all in or out the house that I created
for my family but God is alive the Devil
is a defeated Foe and Kim is a Christian
woman and she's not here just to have
content up on adult channels she's not
here just to have that last interview
magazine uh cover if you look at the two
interview magazine covers look at the
one when I was there and look at the one
when I'm not there and that's the reason
why this Tuskegee experiment of such
that's happened to the black community
where they took the fathers out of the
home and the leaders out of the
community and have torn apart the
community now they've seen that's worked
and they're doing that to America
they're attempting they're trying I mean
that interview the interview the
interview magazine cover you're talking
about I think is the one where she was
basically semi-naked in front of the
American flag and I thought that was
pretty distasteful actually
it was about the American dream and I
thought well if that's the American
dream we're all screwed and I and I
agree with that and I I didn't feel the
platform to voice my opinion because I
wanna it's always like hey this is your
kid's mother this year but it's time
with the leaders like I'm still the
priest of that home Chris I'm still the
priest of that home they they want to
make it this matriarch Society all that
and you know but I am the priest of this
home and God is alive I am the living
Robert Kardashian and I'm gonna stand up
for what God would want as a Christian
and then people say as a Christian or
you're not supposed to curse you're not
supposed to have righteous indignation
but I do you know Christians had swords
also Christians got guns I tell you that
you know so but do you talk to you talk
to Kim I mean there have been reports
here that you and Kim don't really talk
at the moment she's distancing herself
from me because of the stuff you've been
saying was getting controversy is that
true
I mean John Legend is distant distancing
my himself from me and buying more
Christmas sweaters in the middle of
spring also so I'm not saying that you
know they're making the right decisions
uh she's being influenced you know but I
guarantee you what's not gonna happen
we're not going to see anyone in them
John Legend Christmas sweaters no time
soon but do you talk to her are you
still in touch wait a minute don't you
think it's like don't you think it's
like funny to like make a joke out of
stuff sometimes don't you think like God
has a sense of humor oh God but watch
this God God when I got married I bought
this house I like you know what I'm
saying I did this tour and spent all the
money I had on this house to like
surprise Kim and give her this house
that she wanted that Lisa Marie Presley
used to own and
um and then I got the house and then I
put all this money into renovation and
then there goes the neighborhood Drake
moves down the street five blocks and
that's when I knew God was funny but
watch this is where God is even funnier
here he goes like Louis CK part two
level because Louis CK is the funniest
man alive uncancel him now right
sorry are you sad that you're no longer
together that you're divorced
we'll always be together
she dresses exactly like me what do you
mean like my kids are me you know
there's no person that you'll ever get
with that will influence her more than
God and then her priest on Earth which
is me you know whether it's the the
skims clothing line the designers the
The Architects all those people you got
the clintons the left
utilizing what we built together to try
to use her as an influence for the black
culture and this word culture in general
for the next elections they need those
300 million followers from Kylie and Kim
on their side going into their election
as they push trauma culture to the black
people again as they claim anything any
my questions of business dealings to be
anti-semitic comments and push you know
Kim to you know as a billionaire mother
of a lawyer and a mother of four Jew
black children
uh
uh to do covers like interview do you
still love Kim
I absolutely love I love her for life
and I pray and I will protect oddly
enough I'll actually protect her because
when I call out things that I feel are
wrong you know what I'm saying when I
make products like say the difference
between me and Bernard are no like say
watch Elon Musk every product the reason
why Elon Musk is like a Steve Jobs is
if he makes a flamethrower he would use
that flamethrower if he makes a cyber
truck he would use that cyber truck me
if I make some 3D printed boots you know
I'm gonna have the the 3D printed boots
on Wow every day can I get a pair
absolutely sir
These Boots Are a hit love fuzz yes
those are fantastic I've wanted to
interview you for years yeah I genuinely
mean it when I say I think you're one of
the most brilliant talented people that
I've seen in the public sphere and you
have a lot of fascinating ideas and
you're incredibly creative and you're
completely entitled to your views but
I'm entitled to mine um I think we've
had some really uh really interesting
exchanges actually let me ask you about
someone we haven't mentioned Vladimir
Putin and what he's been doing in
Ukraine what is your view of that
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
hi
[Music]
do not believe in war
and I believe
that there is ways that America could
have avoided
this war
but
Biden has money Biden has reasons for us
to be at War right now for selfish
reasons and what I would like to do
without giving you too much information
I would like to speak with my political
advisors to give you the exact
uh exact information I'm not gonna hey
watch this one pierce I'm not going to
shoot from the hip on this one
especially talking about war and things
as sensitive as Ukraine and the Russian
war no no we already got that um the
[ __ ] comment earlier that we could
work on that I feel like is going to be
massively offensive and I really do all
right now that one I do apologize to
people that offended earlier in the
interview on that comment maybe we could
look at scrubbing that if we if we if we
deem well actually actually I would say
I would say this it's an uncensored
interview you said something which
you've now wished you hadn't said and
you've apologized I actually think that
says a lot about you right that shows
you've got that ability to be self-aware
to understand when you cross a line I
think someone like you with all your
energy and creativity and your passion
you're gonna say stuff the way that you
talk constantly and in such an
extraordinary manner you're gonna trip
Bob you're going to say things the wrong
way I don't think there's anything wrong
and when you do that doing what you just
did and saying I'm sorry I crossed a
line I apologize it's actually quite
empowering
do you
you know what I think you know what I
think I'll go ahead and do
I feel that I've given the platform
and I think by holding the idea of an
apology hostage is not Godlike correct I
feel like we have to free
yeah you know and I think that's the
point that you've been making and
because we sat down and had this
conversation
you know
I will say I'm sorry for the people that
I heard with the Defcon the the
confusion that I call I feel like I call
her I cause hurt and confusion and I'm
sorry for the families of the people
that had nothing to do with the the
trauma that I had been through and that
I use my platform where you say hurt
people hurt people and I I was hurt I
was frustrated and I want to say that
it's wrong to hold an apology hostage
and I gotta let go of that and free you
know free myself of the trauma and say
look I'm just gonna give it all up to
God right now and say to those families
that I heard you know I really want to
give you guys a big hug and I want to uh
I say I'm sorry for hurting you with my
comments and I want to word it and not a
pres and not in like a political way but
in a presidential way which means what I
knew a president to be when I was
growing up and a sincere way you know
how people give those kind of I want to
give an apology and you're like but did
you you know what I'm saying like no it
has to be I want to go to every person's
grandmother and grandfather
and every person's son and daughter aunt
and uncle and give them a hug and say
you know what I've been hurt
and I do want you to talk to your boys I
do want you to talk to the people that
are in power the people who do own the
black voice the people who do own the
black void the vote which a lot of
Jewish business people do and I I want
to be able to sit at the table with the
contracts I want my people to sit at the
table with the contracts I do want all
of this but I'm not going to hold my
apology hostage till I get that I'm
going to start by taking accountability
for my actions and the lack of
sophistication in my wording like I said
I was sleepy and it was taken
and in a way that I didn't mean to me to
be taken it definitely caused some
attention but I don't want the
conversation to go away just because I
came to you guys and said you know I
understand how I hurt you and I'm sorry
for the pain that I've caused and the
confusion that I cause now that is said
right but I don't want the conversation
to go away that we are still in a place
where these contracts are still
my people are still getting screwed this
has to be opened up and I'm not asking
for a promise but it would be a
beautiful world as as I release the pain
that I've caused and the pain that I
have in me that Grudge that I was
holding that you guys some of you guys
one two of you guys step up and say
let's look at these contracts let's make
it not be a known fact that the music
industry is treacherous let's make it
because my kids so my kids do music you
know I don't want them to step into a
treacherous place I wanted to be better
for them than it was for me so I wanted
to sit down and come together and really
work on that what would that make sense
to you pierce you know what you ate if
you simply said that in your tweet I
don't think there would have been any
problem
and I'm very very pleased actually that
we've got to a place where you felt able
to say that and I think it was sincere
um
I get it I get it but what you've now
done you've now explained the context of
the problem and you also issued a
sincere apology to people who were
rightly offended by the way you phrased
what you said so I think that's a that's
a good place to finish the interview and
I I'm very glad you got there
okay but it's not finished the idea is
not finished I understand that there's
that there's still a problem I
understand no one's going to be in any
doubt there's a problem and by the way
I'm sure there is I'm sure that a lot of
the contracts in the music business are
rigged against people uh like like
artists like yourself I'm sure of it
it's always been the case from Elvis yes
so I I guess would you would you would
you help me and my people would you help
me and my my athletes I got so many
athletes that go to my school that are
like all the guys that are on down there
are headed to the NBA right could you
help me could you help us make these
contracts better for our people by call
calling attention by just allowing me on
your platform right and let's look at
some of the things and point these
things out could could we work together
I'm absolutely happy in the Years very
happy to do that yeah very happy to do
that I think we should talk more often
all right it's taken a long time to get
here I've thoroughly enjoyed our
conversation it's been two hours it's
been free rolling it's been occasionally
challenging but we've got to a place
where I think it's a good place and I've
really enjoyed it so thank you very much
indeedia for sparing me the time okay
you know you know I'm gonna feel like
I love I I lost my stone I was holding
yeah
yeah but but I but I had to give it up
to God you know what I'm saying like yes
it you know you're gonna be bragging
you're going to be bragging at dinner
tonight like yo I talked to yay no one
could do it no one could do it I did it
and you know
I'm I'm I'm giving you this and I'm
gonna pray that you as a fellow believer
in Christ will help me to expose all the
wrong that's still currently happening
to my people specifically in the
entertainment industry because honestly
I'm very happy to start with I'm very
happy to hold anyone to account who is
behaving improperly honestly and I'm I'm
absolutely certain that that
entertainment business is riddled with
people who try it on and exploit people
and I would be very happy to help you to
expose that but for now I've got to
leave it yay we've had two hours it's
been remarkable thank you very much for
your time
peace well that's super Delight an
extraordinary interview whatever you're
up to Keep It Uncensored
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign